you can keep all of the money you can
keep some of the money or you could
choose to give all of the money away if
you decide not to keep it all what's
ever left is gonna go help another
family who may be in as much need or
maybe more losses legen war what an
unselfish act for him to do this
decision has nothing to do with me it
has to do with my family my girls I want
them to look at me when they grow hold
her and save it Browdy
both view we're giving a briefcase with
$100,000 cash and have been deciding on
whether to share any money with each
other through it all they'll learn that
it's not the money but the journey that
will teach them what they value most